Let's look more at what we got from dir(s).
We can see that the first part of it all these parts up to here.
All these methods start with two underscores. We have names like None.
These also known as special method names or more co-locally known as magic methods
and the reason they're magic is that they can be used in special ways.
For example, the _eq method, well that's the one that's used when we have a double equal.
Another interesting one is the _str method.
This is what happens when we print s, it's actually turning that into str of s,
and str uses this method.
So, for this quiz, your goal is to find the set method
that will provide the desired behavior that we specified for union.
So, if we do a.. method passing in b, that would mutate a to be the union of a and b.
We haven't told you what that method is yet but you should be able to figure it out yourself
using experiments as well as the documentation if necessary.